[Musik]
was soll ich damit
ich kann auch kein fisch zum frühstück
essen das kita platz bekommen bei einem
neuen video ja ich hoffe natürlich euch
geht's gut ich habe letztens irgendwann
muss ich zeigen einen kommentar gelesen
zu einem video von mir ich habe ja in
letzter zeit immer dort felder geworfen
wir hatten einmal schon dort fall
bestimmt das restaurant wir hatten schon
einmal dort fall bestimmt welche
klamotten ich bestelle und der fall
bestimmt wohin ich fliege also
eigentlich vollkommen ich hab's gefunden
ich bin mal kurz die einen kannst du mal
so ein video macht mit der dartscheibe
also du glaubst und einem tag nur das
essen was an der dartscheibe mit einem
pfeil trifft wäre bestimmt witzig
natürlich habe ich schon so ein paar
gemacht also so ähnlich ich meine das
war der erste partner von ich verlinke
euch auf jeden fall auf alle anderen
platz in der video beschreibung und am
ende schaut euch die auf jeden fall noch
an wenn ihr es noch nicht gesehen hat
vor allem das mit der reise das war
eigentlich ein cooles zufällig genau und
ich habe mich eben hingesetzt habe eine
stunde eine karte entworfen ich zeige es
euch mal kurz wie die aussieht
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt schon ausgedrückt war
wieder ein baumarkt hat der neue dacia
apple gekauft also wen nicht derzeit
eine neue pinnwand gekauft weil die
andere habe ich wenn meine eltern
vergessen und ich würde sagen wir lagern
gar nicht lange und fangen direkt man
weiß ich noch kurz sagen wollte wir sind
jetzt schon bei 34 prozent von allen
leuten die dieses video schon habe ich
auch abonniert deswegen abonniert auf
jeden fall falls es nicht getan hat
würde ich mich wirklich selber freuen
hier haben wir die map sieht finde ich
echt ganz cool aus es ist eigentlich von
jedem was dabei wir haben eine menge
gesundes zum beispiel obst erdbeeren
bananen salat rauben melone gibt aber
auch ein paar ungesunde sagt ich habe
mein burger mit reingenommen eine pizza
das ist halt irgendwie so relativ normal
ausgerichtet ist sowie die meisten
menschen halt essen nicht auch jetzt
wenn ich habe ich es aber auch gerne man
salat ich muss euch sagen wir haben es
schon mittag werden morgen habe ich
müsste gegessen deswegen können wir
einfach mal mittags an
es geht also von jetzt prüfen 20 stunden
wie immer muss mir noch kurz eine
markierung machen so pro mahlzeit werden
immer drei pfeile geworfen
ich hoffe ich treffe und während ich
wieder gegen die wand erster fall
diesmal auch ohne katz damit ich wieder
irgendwelche von euch sagen ich denke
das erste unglück nicht in die wand
gegangen wir werfen den nächsten
[Musik]
oh das ist schon mal gar nicht mal so
schlecht wir haben hier oben der die
salat getroffen ja hier eine ganz
normale salatbar kann man sich auf jeden
fall mit zufrieden geben nächster zeit
wieder nicht getroffen
radprofi werde ich in diesem leben auch
nicht mehr
das ist jetzt schwierig auch wir haben
hier meist die frage ist jetzt soll ich
noch extras oder eine wird in den salat
reinschmeißen ich würde einfach mal
sagen wir kombinieren dass beim pizza
oder fast schon wieder der salat und
jetzt haben wir einfach eine pizza noch
dazu eine pizza muss ja nicht unbedingt
immer ungesund sein ok und der letzte
fall war es das den möhren lecker der
leute das hier sind die märchen pizza
man kann sogar sehen damit jetzt auch
keine sagen kann ich habe ja 123 mal
daneben einmal in den mais einmal in die
märchen die pizza einmal in den salat
eines eigens ausgehobene mittagsmahlzeit
ich habe finde ich ganz gut geworfen ich
würde sagen wir machen pizza salat mit
löchern die könnte ich eigentlich auch
in den salat umarmen wir müssen erst mal
einkaufen wird sagen los geht's übrigens
sowie dass ich heute nicht so brach
aufsehen und reibt man die kommentare
steht mir das oder nicht
jetzt fehlen nur noch hören so wir
suchen noch pizzabelag ist der teig kann
ich noch zu hause und das wichtigste
käse
[Musik]
ich will wieder da vom eigentlich auch
in einer ich sehe heute wenig aus wie so
ein schuljunge
das hätte heute ist echt wahnsinn können
damit jetzt auch eine gamescom
bootsfahrt folgen laut wird es mal
wieder auf diese kamera hier so ich bin
hier ist gekauft salat märchen mais und
pizza allerdings pizza zum selbermachen
deshalb viel gesünder als steinofen
pizza aus dem ofen findet wichtigster
teil kamen mir sogar noch im kühlschrank
will das jetzt eigentlich so weiter
geiste schmeckt irgendwie finde wenn man
den benutzer über den can schmeckt am
meisten nach pizza wieder angesagt so
noch immer einen koch video machen dass
auf jeden fall mal daumen nach oben da
wir darauf bock habt dann gibt es das in
fukushima jetzt kommt dieses
wunderschöne werk erstmal in den ofen
und das wetter ist eigentlich gut wir
machen uns einfach mal an den salat
kleine vorspeise
[Musik]
ja klar kommen die die sich fragen
kriegst du eigentlich gar nichts also
ich habe mir natürlich gedacht was da
kann ich immer trinken ist ja auch
logisch es geht also nur um essen und
ich habe da glaube ich auch an der wand
so orangensaft ist dabei eistee und ja
das war es weil orangensaft frühstück
und so bringt mir manche ich zum
beispiel pizza ist fertig ich habe mir
auch schon mal ein stück hier eingeholt
bin ich echt ganz gut aus man muss sagen
ich war sehr hart aber jetzt gleich
geht's auch schon los lang sich so
gamescom partie wobei wir vorher noch in
die stadt gehen und deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht ich werfe die fall schon mal
vorher weil ich dann natürlich heute
abend schauen kann wo ich das hier
bekomme was ich werfe deswegen nehme ich
euch natürlich später mit allerdings
nicht mit der kamera sondern nur mit
meinem handy weil ich zu essen findet
schaut euch diese zweite kamera mit der
er durch die stadt zweier dann kann man
sich gar nicht wirklich entspannen
würden mal auf diese dumme kamera
aufpassen muss das ist übrigens sehr
rest von der pizza einiger marken trick
gemacht sieht minister im spiegel
gut da immer das team muss ich mich
selber einmal sonst komme ich zu spät
feilt nummer eins ach du scheiße was
verpasst denn der arme tische und ruhm
was haben wir denn hier bananen da war
habe ich sogar noch hier feiern nummer
zwei boom hier ganz knapp an der jury
vorbei müssen wir nochmal werden
denn ich bin so dumm junge junge die
armen möbel war ja gut gemüse
es ist wenigstens gesund haribo also
werden theoretisch für heute abend eine
banane irgendwas mit gemüse ein bürger
mit gemüse ich weiß jetzt nicht und dem
haribo ist habe ich eigentlich ein
gefahren also zwischendurch sorgt aber
so ist das
wir machen uns jetzt auf den weg ich
muss mich beeilen los gehts zur gamescom
bootspartie youtubes partie ist eine
party auf dem boot mit ganz vielen
verschiedenen jubel ich freue mich auch
eine menge leute mal wieder zu sehen und
ja ich nehme handy mit es später
gestatten mit der banane weil robben
energy stellt dr
ich kommentiere das mal kurz im
hintergrund hier war mir eine shisha bar
und ich glaube jetzt hat er seinen
genauso ein handys runter gefallen
[Musik]
er versteht nicht wahrscheinlich eh
nicht aber so wenig gemüse gibt es hier
nicht eigentlich schade
ja das war youtube party die war direkt
unter der hohenzollernbrücke in köln
die war allerdings um 23 uhr zu ende
dann wenn wir auf die andere rheinseite
gang und wollten zu dieser pinken party
das war die partie da sind wir nicht
reingekommen und dann war ich bei ford
eine party und nicht von die balance
toll und dann wieder zurück dann morgen
später ich war gestern auch erst um halb
drei glauben hier jetzt erst mal lust
die 3d zu werfen für das frühstück
ansieht wahrscheinlich auch noch dass
ich ziemlich müde bin also ich werde
jetzt erstmal kurz und dann erzähle ich
euch was gestern so ablegen bei ich
glaube ich kann nicht alles festhalten
mein handy war irgendwann leer ich bin
und 40 prozent aus dem haus gegangen
vielleicht war gespannt vielleicht
treffe ich jetzt was cooles und
schauspieler banane was ich extrem viel
ich jetzt mal drauf nein was haben wir
hier ein sandwich guck mal da sieht man
mal wie gut ich doch dafür bewerben kann
ganz knapp an den pancakes vorbei
oder was soll ich damit
boah ich kann doch keinen fisch zum
frühstück essen es ist irgendwie ein
bisschen dumm gerade ich habe so einen
fisch ist zb mit reingenommen damit es
auch lustig werden kann
aber eigentlich eher für abends und spaß
das kann ich nicht machen da konnte ich
das jetzt schon also wir haben
es handle sich gut das ist dann halt so
heute ist es extrem heiß fällt mir
gehört auch so deutlich weil dort
einkaufen ob jetzt noch schnell die
haare gemacht haben ich will dieses hier
jetzt wieder gut aussehe und ich wollte
ich jetzt einfach ich habe halt einfach
fisch gekauft hat keinen plan war damit
anstellen sollen es war das erste mal in
meinem leben dass ich frisch gekauft hab
gestern abend habe ich mir noch mal
geben
harry muss gekauft weil ich nämlich
vorher hugo waren gestern erst auf
seinem boot da waren nicht wie youtube
hat hier die ging allerdings nur bis 23
uhr
und da waren ja viele youtuber und 23
uhr ist natürlich noch ein bisschen früh
für und wir wollten doch woanders hin
und wollten dann zunächst ob die tritsch
party ich hab' ich glaube ich auch eben
schon kurze ausschnitte gezeigt die
tritsch party war nämlich auf der
anderen seite von köln also köln es ja
praktisch der ein trend der köln wir
sind sodann eineinhalb kilometer
dahingegangen zu fuß war recht weil
irgendwie und ich fand es nicht lustig
weil auf der bildwand ich bin ja kein
twitter ich war nicht auf der liste oder
so das war doch wirklich so richtig
große youtuber dabei also keine ahnung
mit sonst was die vielen millionen
abonnenten und nicht mal die sind da
reingekommen bin wohl einfach alle
wieder weggeschickt einfach weil youtube
nicht so mag keine ahnung da sind wir
weiter zu forschen party die vor allem
nicht in so einem insm touren oben in
köln und da wie es ist dann kommen alle
rein leichen aus einem grund weil die
ganzen leute die bei der formel 1 party
eingeladen waren auch entweder bei der
youtube hat dabei der tritsch party
eingeladen man bei der folgenden partie
absolut gar nichts mehr los wird ja auch
kein vor neid oder so
da war ich auch nicht eingeladen aber
das war kein problem also es war
eigentlich echt ein lustiger abend
ich glaube die party war dann auch schon
so um 12 vorbei und was ich eigentlich
nur sagen wollte es tut mir sehr leid
aber ich habe gestern abend absolut kein
gemüse gefunden ich habe ich diese karte
folge lesen da gab es alles mögliche
außer irgendwas vernünftiges gesundes
was ich essen wollte ich habe jetzt
berufen ein sandwich und einstellungen
jetzt gleich auch schon wieder 24 schon
rum ich wollte noch den fisch zeigen mit
dem ich ihr könnt gerne macht ihr könnt
gerne meine kommentare schreiben was man
damit machen kann
die man zubereitet und wenn ich zeige
euch das mal kurz also wir haben hier
spross köln heißt das glaube ich oder
floskeln hier sind wirklich so kleine
baby fische drin eigentlich hasse ich
wirklich aber wenn es irgend ein
vernünftiger kommentar kommt von euch
was ich damit machen kann oder wie ich
den zu bereiten soll
dann gibt es das natürlich im nächsten
video deswegen schreibe es in die
kommentare so also ich muss sagen das
sieht ja eigentlich ständig lecker aus
ist ein panini sandwich also leute ich
hoffe ihr habt einen coolen kommentar
geschrieben was mit dem fisch machen
kann ich habe keinen plan auf dieses
video lang ist oder nicht weiß ich nicht
ich habe einfach spontan angefangen
gestern ich hoffe es hat euch
einigermaßen gefallen wir sehen uns
morgen wieder wahrscheinlich gibt es ein
neues video abonnieren ich vergessen
habe ich am anfang schon gesagt rund bis
sein verein sechs natürlich instagram